loading a new year Brendon whoa expect
that talking politics to unsuspecting
festival goes the x music festival in
Cardiff hosts more than 30,000 young
dance music fans not the sort of place
you'd expect referendum campaigners to
venture that's exactly why we're here we
need to find out are they in are they
out today no and more importantly do
they care
they are going to load out to Ghana
something needs to change basically I
think seem to like emigrate I think I
think voyage system would work EU
referendum in or out despite the polls
then these young voters are far more
mixed than the remained side would like
they're all so far more fired up than
popular opinion suggests even at a
festival how are you voting in the EU
referendum no no I don't know I haven't
made my mind up we all know she talked
about it a little bit miss handy what do
you think about the EU referendum well I
think we should remain that's my monomer
you think you should remain okay you
also the same I think the wishes same
ish is this something that you are
talking about amongst your friends yeah
we are
now the debate value for their work I'm
still undecided i haven't actually I
mean I've been I went to a few debates
at Cardiff puny there was a good one on
in the business school and that's good i
was very much in in in in but then that
did swimming patch yeah yeah Pat
remembered so you debate at your unique
suede you it hasn't swayed me company I
won't say i'm going to be doing breaks
it quite yet far I'm not you're just
yeah yeah I my people yeah are you gonna
drop the bball I tell it is my facebook
name but mostly because breaks it's a
catchy word it is something that you
know amongst you amongst your your mates
do you talk about this sort of thing
yeah we do yeah I don't know dude I
think what happens quite a lot which is
you know I'm surprised about that as I'm
sure you've caught some who are less
interested but for the masses here at
least it seems the referendum is shaping
up to be the festival of democracy we
were promised
Joe tidy sky news in cab
you